president biden is adding specifics to
his build back better plan by calling
for a massive hike in government
spending in a six
trillion dollar budget proposal for
fiscal year 2022
while this includes the still debated
infrastructure jobs creation plan and
his family health care proposals
republicans have already said it's a
non-starter on friday republican
senators also blocked the appointment of
a bipartisan commission
to investigate the january 6th
insurrection at the u.s capitol
christina roufini is at the white house
this morning with the very latest
christina good morning
good morning dana if you remember about
a month ago we talked about that preview
sort of coming attractions trailer
budget that the white house had unveiled
well the full blockbuster budget
premiered yesterday and it's big
it's bold and it's designed to get your
attention even though it's unlikely to
ever get past
this time there's sunlight at the end of
the tunnel there's real life
standing in front of a massive indoor
rock wall in northern virginia
president biden said the u.s economy has
started to climb its way
out of the covid crevasse we've gone
from pain
and stagnation of a long dark winter
to an economy on the move
in order to keep that ascent going the
white house is proposing what it calls a
transformational six trillion dollar
budget
it includes previously announced
programs like the 1.7 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill
and a 1.8 trillion dollar american
families plan
the budget does exactly the president
told the country that he would do
grow the economy create jobs but
republicans in congress are calling the
proposal
dead on arrival but it's not free
there's no such thing as a free
lunch the two parties were already at
odds over the price of the president's
infrastructure plan
the motion is not agreed to and
yesterday republicans blocked a
bipartisan commission
to investigate the january 6 capital
riot
senate republicans chose to defend the
big lie
because they believe anything that might
upset donald trump could hurt them
politically
the motion needed 10 republicans to
proceed it only got six
alaska's lisa murkowski was one of them
truth
is hard stuff but we've got a
responsibility to it
the commission would have had the power
to subpoena witnesses
including possibly former president
trump about their role in what happened
that day
with the midterm elections looming in
2022
the former president had warned of
consequences for any republicans who
voted in the commission's favor
now when it comes to the budget remember
that congress not the white house holds
the purse strings
and if the two parties can't agree on
something like a bipartisan commission
it seems more than just a little
unlikely they're going to be able to
come together on trillions in new
spending
we'll have to see how that budget plays
on capitol hill but jeff i'd expect
a lot of rewrites sounds about right
christina thank you very much